thomas bach clarín es el primo mayor de
george white nunca imaginó que un
miembro de su familia sería asesinado
durante un control policial
sender
y saber que todo el mundo está hablando
de mi primo se siente raro pero me
enorgullece saber que la gente reconoce
que no murió por nada
hoy más que nunca es para que su primo
pueda ser un símbolo del cambio en eeuu
un cambio que requiere la condena de
dirección
esperamos un juicio rápido con un
veredicto que lo declara culpable
hemos visto morir a demasiadas personas
a manos de agentes del policía
especialmente personas desarmadas eso
tiene que cambiar la policía y los
ciudadanos tienen que interactuar de
manera diferente que yo sepa el deber de
la policía es servir y proteger no dañar
y matar
[Música]
en mayo de 2020 una muerte de georg hoy
envolvió en llamas a eeuu
[Aplausos]
nueva york/washington portland en todo
el país
estadounidenses de todas las comunidades
salieron a la calle para exigir justicia
y una reforma policial
la desaparición de george floyd también
ha llevado a los ciudadanos a formar
grupos de vigilancia para proteger a su
comunidad
ellos mismos estos hombres armados son
los combatientes de la libertad de línea
nos encontramos con ellos en el lugar
donde george floyd murió bajo la rodilla
de direct xavi exploran la zona para
saber dónde posicionarse y así proteger
una manifestación que tendrá lugar unos
días después en cada punto de acceso
necesitaremos un lugar destinado a
interceptar e inmovilizar posibles
elementos perturbadores es hora de bajar
la atención y luego sacarlos jamail
jackson es su comandante en la vida
cotidiana este padre de 43 años es
profesor y entrenador de baloncesto pero
en cuanto es necesario se convierte en
guardia de seguridad para compensar los
excesos de la policía y evitar las
incursiones de grupos hostiles una de
nuestras misiones como combatientes por
la libertad es proporcionar protección
dentro de nuestra propia comunidad si
nos llaman y nos necesitan para proteger
un evento siempre que podamos hacerlo lo
haremos
los combatientes de la libertad tienen
grandes expectativas en el juicio de
derek saben quién enfrenta tres cargos
un policía podría pagar hasta 40 años de
prisión personalmente quiero ver una
condena quiero que esto conduzca a una
verdadera reforma policial que haya un
cambio fundamental en la forma de actuar
de nuestra policía en nuestras calles y
comunidades
por desgracia pase lo que pase habrá
resentimiento en ambos lados de la
división racial estadounidense la
situación es muy tensa en este momento
por el veredicto algunos estadounidenses
estarán muy disgustados y expresaron su
ira de una u otra manera
en minnesota nunca se ha condenado a un
policía blanco por matar a un hombre
negro sin embargo hay muchos casos según
la asociación comunidades unidas contra
la violencia policial en minnesota más
de 400 afroamericanos han muerto en
requisas desde el año 2000 y nunca han
sido condenados
hay que entender que el sistema judicial
de ese país ha sido diseñado para atacar
a la gente de color por otro lado cuando
los blancos están involucrados de
repente el sistema se vuelve apático no
quiero seguir viviendo así no quiero
vivir en un estado policial en el que un
grupo de hombres ya sean blancos o
negros tienen licencia para matarme si
creen que infringido la ley
los grupos de defensa de los
afroamericanos de mineápolis se
reunieron ese día en la oficina de nick
y málev i am song una activista de los
derechos civiles y defensora de la
reinvención total de la policía si somos
realmente serios aquí en línea policía
en cualquier otro lugar de nuestro
estado examinaremos específicamente el
papel que desempeña la policía no nos
conformaremos con la clásica explicación
que tal o cual funcionario era una oveja
negra y ya está no lo que pasó es parte
de un racismo sistémico de la supremacía
blanca que permitió que gente como
derecho bing y estos otros tres policías
se sintieran con derecho a hacer lo que
hicieron esta es una institución que se
construyó a cuestas de los negros cuando
se puso fin a la esclavitud es difícil
ser optimista cuando se piensa en la
capacidad de esta institución para
reformarse realmente creo que lo que se
necesita es una revisión completa los
primeros testigos en el juicio de derek
saben están siendo escuchados en la
corte de minneapolis se espera que el
proceso dure entre 3 y 4 semanas antes
de que el jurado delibere un veredicto
esperado por todo el país